hey 42 here have you ever woken up in
the middle of the night with an eerie
feeling that someone or something is
watching you or maybe you've seen a pair
of eyes in the darkness staring back at
you and deep into your soul are demons
responsible for these spine-tingling
moments are demons even real and is it
possible to become possessed by one
these terrifying real-life stories seem
to suggest that they're more than just
fables these demonic possession stories
will surely send shivers down your spine
first up is the possession of
german-born
Annalise Michelle this terrifying
account was so convincing that Hollywood
couldn't help themselves but make a film
out of it the 2005 film The Exorcism of
Emily Rose was based on the real-life
case of Anneliese Michelle Michelle had
always had problems whilst growing up
she suffered from epilepsy and mental
illness for which she was treated at a
psychiatric hospital however it was not
until 1973 when Michelle was 20 years
old when things really started to get
weird Michelle became suicidal she
started to vehemently reject all
religious objects and symbols she drank
her own urine and started hearing voices
which told her to rot in hell she also
started seeing the faces of Devils
Catholic bishop Joseph Stangl used his
utmost authority as a member of the
Catholic Church to deduce that this
behavior wasn't normal for a 20 year old
girl and she was likely possessed by a
demon
Stangl performed an exorcism ritual in
total secrecy over the next 10 months
Michelle had a staggering 70s isms
performed on her meanwhile her parents
stopped treating her epilepsy and mental
disorders after a year of this she died
of dehydration and malnutrition the
priests who conducted the exorcisms were
found guilty of manslaughter and
sentenced to six months behind bars I
think there's an important lesson here
if the first 20 exorcisms don't work out
the next 50 probably aren't going to
iver
next up is the unnerving story of
michael taylor who lived with his wife
christian in a small town called oz 't
in Great Britain the couple were very
religious and regularly attended a
Christian prayer group at one peculiar
meeting in 1974 Michael's wife Christine
Taylor accused her husband of having an
affair with the leader of the prayer
group
Taylor obviously wasn't too pleased with
this accusation because he began to spew
obscenities at his wife and started to
act extremely erratic which was very
much out of character for him
witnesses concluded that he had been
possessed by some kind of evil spirit
this insane behavior continued for
months until Taylor eventually consulted
a priest he performed an exorcism on him
which lasted for a grueling 24 hours
according to the priests involved in the
exorcism they removed 40 demons from
Taylor's body however the priests warned
him that the demons may still have
remained dormant in his soul and they
weren't far wrong because Taylor then
went home and brutally murdered his wife
and their dog after which he wandered
the streets for hours covered in blood
before being arrested next up is the
real-life accounts that the infamous
1974 film The Exorcist is based on but
there's a twist the actual possession
happened to a male not a female like in
the film the actual possession happened
to 14 year old Roland doe which is
actually not his real name the Catholic
Church assigns this pseudonym to him to
protect the boys privacy the
bone-chilling real-life story goes like
this it was a late 1940s in Cottage City
Maryland and Roland doe attempted to
contact his late on for a Ouija board
many believe this is what opened the
door to a flurry of demons who wished to
possess him unfortunately the countless
horror films where Little Jimmy finds a
Ouija board in the Attic and
accidentally brings through a thousand
evil demons hadn't yet been made so poor
Roland doe was none the wiser his family
started to hear strange sounds around
the
such as scratches dripping water and
unexplained footsteps then religious
artifact started flying from the walls
then dough levitated into the air his
body unnaturally contorted speaking in
tongues in a guttural voice it was about
then that the boy's family decided it
was about time to do something about
this unnatural behavior
they brought in a priest to perform an
exorcism the ritual was performed over
30 times before the priests deemed it
successful though injured the priest
multiple times during the exorcisms
those present reported a horrible
sulfuric older lingering in the air
afterwards afterwards dough returned to
his normal life
next up his George Lukens a man from
England in the late 17th century Lukens
was a greedy bugger because he claimed
to be possessed by not one but seven
demons and he requested seven different
priests to remove the demons from his
body it all started when sara barba a
close friend of Lukens noticed that he
had started to act rather strangely
according to barber Lukens had slowly
deteriorated mentally and physically
over the past 18 years he started to
have seizures and growl at people around
him he taught in disturbing supernatural
tones in 1778 seven priests performed a
lengthy exorcism on Lukens at the temple
Church in Bristol England as soon as the
exorcism commenced with one of the
priests singing a hymn Lukens turned
extremely violent and started barking
and hissing at the priests Lukens then
cycled through seven different demonic
personalities over the span of the
exorcism before finally declaring out
loud that he was the devil himself
afterwards according to the priests who
were present the exorcism was a success
the demons were sent back to hell and
George Lukens returned to a normal life
next up is a story of the infamous
serial killer who is supposedly spurred
on to kill by a demon he was known as
the Son of Sam although his real name
was David Berkowitz Berkowitz began
murdering in
1976 and continued his ruthless killing
campaign for an entire year before he
was caught his killings all had a very
similar mo he would approach a stranger
in the dead of night and shoot them with
a 44 revolver then he would leave
immediately
without uttering a word however it one
of the crime scenes the police found a
stomach-turning note left by Berkowitz
the note talked about his father called
Sam who drank blood and kept Berkowitz
locked in an attic the note also said
that farther south commands Berkowitz to
go out and kill but this is the strange
part as if it wasn't strange already
Berkowitz didn't have a father named son
his father was actually called Tony so
who on earth or hell was Sam well get
this according to Berkowitz Sam was the
name of the demon who possessed his
neighbor's dog yes doc when Berkowitz
aka the Son of Sam as he had come to be
known was finally arrested in 1977 after
killing six known victims
he confessed to his murders he explained
how his neighbor's dog was a conduit for
an evil demon and that the dog had
commanded him to carry out every murder
so remember guys if you don't have an
alibi
you can always blame it on the dog
actually no way that doesn't work at all
David Berkowitz got six life sentences
for his evil demon dog field murders
next we go to natal South Africa where
in 1906 a Christian student named Clara
German SLA
started to act very strangely up until
the age of 16 Clara had always been a
very ordinary girl but that's all
changed pretty quickly when Clara
started displaying some rather
incredible yet creepy superhuman powers
Clara started to speak and understand
German French and polish fluently
despite the fact that she had never
studied or even heard these languages
before Clara was also able to reveal the
most into
secrets about people whom she'd never
met before Clara started to mysteriously
levitate vertically out of her bed and
she had superhuman levels of strength
able to throw people twice her size
across the room it is said by witnesses
that her voice sounded like a veritable
herd of wild beasts orchestrated by
Satan Clara later revealed that she had
made a pact with Satan giving him the
ability to take over her body had she
really made a pact with Satan well the
local priest certainly thought so two
priests performed an exorcism on clogger
that lasted two days during which over a
hundred and seventy people witnessed her
levitating several feet in the air
whilst a priest read scriptures after
the exorcism it was a general consensus
of the priests Arno's present that the
evil spirits had been expunged from her
body presumably Satan was displeased
that Clara hadn't kept her end of the
bargain in 2008 a board-certified
psychiatrist in New York Medical College
named dr. Richard Gallagher was given a
very unique opportunity a bishop asked
him to provide a psychiatric analysis of
a woman who claimed to be possessed by
demons usually scientists and doctors
just pass off these cases as mental
illness
what Gallagher put his prejudices aside
and agreed to examine her regardless
during the examination the woman who has
given the pseudonym of Julia to protect
her identity started out completely
normal but then demons obviously
reminded her of the small fact that she
was possessed because she suddenly went
into a trance-like state followed by a
fit of rage she started to shout at
Gallagher and others in the room telling
them to go away you idiots leave her
alone Julia started to shake violently
then objects flew from the shelves after
Gallagher examined Julia a decision was
reached between the bishop and himself
that Julia should be exercised during
the exorcism Julia screamed obscenities
at the priests in Latin and Spanish she
reportedly levitated five centimeters
off the ground
for half an hour and she screamed in
pain when she was sprinkled with holy
water and finally is the infamous murder
trial of an Cheyenne Johnson in 1981
this was the first ever case in the u.s.
where a lawyer pleaded their client's
innocence on the grounds of demonic
possession
in other words he didn't do it it was
the demon but how did Johnson find
himself in court well about a year
earlier
Johnson stabbed his landlord Alan bono
to death with a pocketknife in
Connecticut before the stabbing family
members close to Johnson began having
demonic visions and heard noises in the
house such as footsteps door slamming
and mysterious voices Johnson's fiance's
younger brother David reported seeing an
apparition that looked like
quote/unquote a man with big black eyes
a fin faced with animal features and
jagged teeth pointed ears horns and
hooves
shortly afterwards David started having
convulsions and bruises appeared on his
body he started to shout at the family
in Latin a few days later Johnson
himself said he had also become
possessed it all eventually came to a
climax a few weeks later when the family
held a party in their home according to
everyone who attended the party Johnson
went into a trance
what slowly towards his landlord
growling under his breath then all of a
sudden stabbed him multiple times in the
chest a year later and the judge said
Johnson's murder trial ruled that
demonic possession was not a valid
defense against murder and Johnson was
given a 20-year prison sentence thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 the existence of demonic
possession is a widely held religious
belief in Islamic mythology the jinn are
supernatural beings that can invade the
body within the Christian tradition
exorcism dates back to the New Testament
when Jesus expelled demons are a number
of occasions